[Música]
ah
colombia registrado en este 2020 74
masacres y 291 personas asesinadas esto
es más del doble de lo registrado en
2019 cuando hubo 36 masacres y sin
embargo en 2019 fue la cifra más alta
desde 2014 antes incluso que la firma de
los acuerdos de paz con la guerrilla las
farc de 2016 para hacer una radiografía
de lo que está sucediendo este último
fin de semana hubo seis ataques en los
que murieron tres firmantes de los
acuerdos de paz también una lideresa
social junto a su marido y su hija dos
personas de una comunidad de
afrodescendientes y también dos menores
de edad en un retén militar fueron
asesinadas por las fuerzas armadas todo
esto indica que colombia está viviendo
una reorganización del conflicto armado
con las disidencias de las farc
rearmándose pero también con otros
agentes como la guerrilla de ln
paramilitares narcotraficantes y en
muchos casos también las propias fuerzas
armadas agosto fue el mes más violento
con 16 masacres y precisamente en ese
mes el presidente de colombia iván duque
aseguró que lo que estaba pasando en el
país no eran masacres sino homicidios
colectivos
[Música]
en su informe de septiembre el
presidente de lópez obrador aseguró que
en mexico ya no hay masacres sin embargo
los hechos muestran una realidad
distinta
guanajuato una de las entidades más
azotadas por la delincuencia organizada
es el estado con más matanzas este año
el 27 de septiembre en el municipio de
jaral del progreso una balacera en un
centro nocturno dejó un saldo de 11
muertos tres meses antes también en
guanajuato en el municipio de irapuato
un ataque armado a un centro de
rehabilitación contra las adicciones
dejó sin vida a 26 personas otro ejemplo
es el estado de michoacán en febrero un
comando ejecutó a nueve personas entre
ellas menores de edad en un local de
renta de videojuegos y tres meses
después en el municipio de huetamo
aparecieron los cuerpos de 12 personas
apilados en la batea de una camioneta la
organización causa en común ha
contabilizado más de 500 masacres en los
primeros nueve meses del año y la
secretaria de seguridad pública que
acaba de renovar su titular tiene el
pendiente de reducir la violencia en el
país
[Música]
el salvador registró en los primeros 10
meses del año mil 96 asesinatos un
promedio que se aproxima a 4 homicidios
diarios pero que significa una reducción
de casi el 48 por ciento en comparación
con los ocurridos en el 2019 según
estadísticas policiales el gobierno
adjudica este logro a la implementación
del plan control territorial su
principal estrategia de seguridad sin
embargo en el mes de octubre considerado
el mes más violento del año se
realizaron dos masacres con saldo de 11
fallecidos jornadas violentas como esas
es por las que expertos ponen en duda
que las autoridades hayan quitado el
control del territorio a las pandillas
grupos a los que se les atribuyen la
mayoría de muertes otro fenómeno
vinculado a estas bandas son las
desapariciones registros de la fiscalía
dan cuenta de 824 personas desaparecidas
sólo en el primer semestre de este año
mayoritariamente jóvenes hechos que
suman más angustia y dolor a las
familias salvadoreñas
[Música]